a lot of the meaningful experience of a
role-playing game is not just the
development of the character throughout
the game but the initial character
creation like you said is there
something to that process
that you found to be powerful
like the design of that process because
you think so much about that beginning
what how much should be controlled
how much should be defined the interface
itself
the visual appearance of the character
too because I feel like that you're
loading in you start to load in the
world that you're about to enter by
creating that character right
yeah we think about it a lot it's a
really really good uh comment and
question and it's more than
it has to set the whole stage has to
like pique your interest for the world
you're going to enter
and
we've done it so many different ways
in terms of when you actually go to make
your character when you're making the
choice
and one of the things over time that
we've wanted to avoid is people starting
over
so there's a lot of intentionality
around the types of choices you have
that can be undone or not undone
because what you what game players want
to is I'll play it and then I'll make a
new character
but sometimes they do that because they
realize they made the wrong type of
character
and as a designer you don't want that to
happen
so
some people let me get this comment
Elder Scrolls like oh you simplified it
no no no we move those choices into the
gameplay so that you don't
you know make this character in the
beginning
and then eight hours later realize you
make a horrible mistake
and so okay I'm going to start out like
that to me is a really really bad
experience so also like life itself
[Laughter]
but like life is okay so you can then
fix it in game right I wish I wish I had
learned archery well I'm gonna start
tomorrow yeah
um so you can do that like the Skyrim
character system uh it was really
designed around that all you pick is
like what's your race and that gives you
some things but there's nothing you
can't get then on your own mostly
that sounds weird but you mostly want
that
beginning character generation to be
visual which you then can also change in
the game and some starting skills
that get you off to the type of play
that you want but if you discover you
don't like that type of play as you play
you can move your character along so we
have
moved away post you know Oblivion to a
classless
meaning you don't have a strict
character class Warrior Mage thief
whatever
um in our games and that's that's
continuing for the are you like thinking
of Elder Scrolls six you're already
thinking about that kind of stuff so you
think of early on the the like you said
the first few experiences in the game
you already think it's in them yeah
we know what the first few hours are
like we
we know it's a character system is
basically like and